okay guys we're second back and we're
doing this operation falling feather I
just got on it's been a while their
target and chin aren't going to be happy
if we don't put the skull jack to good
use
we should have one of our soldiers
equipment before they deploy sure I need
[ __ ] more people Oh where's the
[ __ ] where's the recruit sighs sorry
so I'm a dad okay okay he'll say yeah
bye baby daddy I can't daddy like a okay
commander we'll need to have one of our
troops equip the same Jack we're use in
the field
Podcast Red's objective sergeant do we
have any [ __ ] like you it aren't
working if I get there alive okay
that's got a guy that's half that ass
guy Ranger deployed we're in the pipe
five by five I'll say we look for an
easy mission while our skull Jack's
local resistance time say grant us how
sacred Lillian facility tied to the
sabotage at Jack's place the charges and
get the [ __ ] out going in to shut it
down
Forrest approach the target and place
the X for charges at the designated
position and moved to a safe distance
for detonation
hey take out that facility we might just
buy ourselves some time at make knots
and wait loud and clear loud and Clare
minus-15 target coordinates are locked
in move the designated pen that's that
far actually X for charges position is
obscure [ __ ] hang and guys go
straight in where should I go I'll go if
the right I guess got it moving
well thank betches moving everything now
got it
okay honey oh okay yeah I'm gonna patch
it take like [ __ ] ten hours all right
moving out do you say anything now you
know say shut it only neither them right
shut [ __ ] Tiber on [ __ ]
can you see me now so quote
I can't throw from that far can I know
already that already that batches
on the move I can't get up from here
that'd be crazy heading there now shits
you see me yeah good copy human target I
can't get this picture here guy now good
copy
moving on target whoo [ __ ] yeah come on
come on come on [ __ ] come on yeah
[Music]
[ __ ] who say the connection
fuckin'-a there's like everyone here
yeah bye-bye the [ __ ] he doing here
xikar pigeons leather that pick up down
there oh yeah I got the Hulk it should
come out on here moving out this is for
you right yeah get up yeah perfect
- [ __ ] it at red [ __ ] editor now
that's out said that armor bets
did I get it yeah I'm trusting you here
where is
so here's how this match Hey and chest
back oh [ __ ] just gonna live now he'll
attack me isn't he right they're
shifting their attack
yeah live I am [ __ ] my arms pretty
[ __ ] good in this place she's gonna
get me right all right Matt Smith
no no chef [ __ ] a he's gonna light me
up
ah here this guy gets like 30 move shut
[ __ ] okay so this guy always hit the
[ __ ] roof heading that now
oh I miss heading out
whoo our target minimal damage orders
confirmed on the move
oh good god gremlin here myself
don't Yellin that's just [ __ ] run
smack way now your love tracking vehicle
I'd gonna face messed up flip it a
little [ __ ] come on she's gonna ping
this item can he do that I oh wow
Tommy okay let's do it let's go
[ __ ] Cassandra over here she's gonna
kill me oh good I'm surprised that
happened playing and there's Dwayne
times right now that's a [ __ ] egg
what's gonna do what's it gonna do
trying to slightly out place that yeah
taking fire over here sure there's like
50 people
okay so Jeff and him now you use this
guy real quick take off this guy maybe I
can kill two dead that one on the arm
[ __ ] he's almost dead hmm I'm still
holding
[Music]
what the [ __ ] I shot the wrong person
see the mess yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] tell me [ __ ]
have hit him yeah yeah
I hope they lose their [ __ ] shield
now I got to Google stuff I'm under fire
come on just shoots disappear now the
shizzle and last ago certain amount of
time right
Sekulow I can't tell Fiamma
come on loser she'll bet oh good you got
me good come on mess mess mess mess mess
yeah mess again this won't you miss so
far away taking heavy fire
who's your [ __ ] shields either the
shoulder there we go
[ __ ] a
he's a shield bærum [ __ ] good
riddance well I should eliminate him I
want to name him hostiles pacified
yes this guy is the guy I'm worried
about I hope you're [ __ ] wrong
we should come marry you can't get me
for that honey she will be not gonna
come hey tell me fire
she'll bear [ __ ] I got a killer look
over me this is so far away which is
[ __ ] mrs. commander Menace one five
is taking heavy casualties down there if
it looks like we can't complete the
objective we should consider pulling the
squad out shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] let's
rock
Wow I gotta reload this one [ __ ] high
barely [ __ ] up here
see what happens okay it's a little
different now taken care of something
weird huh I guess it is truly random me
she had sky hits me now because I think
this guy that shot me luck I'm insoluble
zucchini [ __ ] mr. time nothing weird
these guys make everything right thank
you [ __ ] a I can't move - ain't got a
bench
this crystal panicking yeah please mess
yeah oh [ __ ] I'm pinned down here
incoming fire
alright lady should lose your [ __ ]
alright yes
critical okay yeah am i doing good to be
eliminated [ __ ] all right what happens
[Music]
he looks so far away now thank God hey
Zack
not early missing and coming over here
darn again truck rolling up there we
love we're green to go I think psyching
to get anyone that's affirmative and we
love this guy realizes they're gonna
shoot the man [ __ ] ridiculous
there's no way Oh what the [ __ ]
hey damn it
that was close with this guy stuff like
us who he gotta
on the move let's pray all we could do
is pray what we got target disabled
you're the stable you doing an awful
good if we a better than I do
let's say [ __ ] net wide
oh I'm good so what you're gonna do now
ok got some [ __ ] Gobber gonna shoot me
please don't head [ __ ] at all you go
now there with lemonade this guy not
[ __ ] dead yeah what the [ __ ]
[Music]
chug it down
I can't Michael we kill commander Venice
1 5 is okay I think if I kill him right
now
they're gonna send a recruit so let me
just [ __ ] him see if I can plan it
[ __ ] leave
tenfold here's my little rock jetty
minus-15 you're near the target position
I know [ __ ] loser again where's he
going
she's my [ __ ] from there we solve it
he sees me
good to go families are there going on
here
Oh traveling I can't get the [ __ ] out
there so this one five status confirmed
x4 charges are armed move to the
extraction point for immediate even
where is it where is it
for the foxy attraction point running
[ __ ] with the clock taking heavy fire
what the [ __ ] is going on here
they got me this wanna shoot shoot them
[ __ ] a buck mess in it with the fog
they're all over me 5 be advised we've
picked up hostile reinforcements inbound
on your position oh my god
please miss heading out please miss
please master commander adventists
jamming the x4 transponder signal
we can't detonate [ __ ] okay
fuckin'-a fuckin'-a
maybe this one who are so [ __ ] close
I can suck my dick
menace 1 5 status confirmed x4 charges
are armed move to the extraction point
for immediate evac operative chef you
know oh gosh no voy Oh dancing an
opposition Menace one five be advised
we've picked up hostile reinforcements
inbound on your position
I needed here a case up moving again
here get the [ __ ] out of here just in
time
menace 1 5 status confirmed charges
very portable
thank you guys thank you for watching
thank you for watching
it's another [ __ ] shower take our data
thank you